هنا في مقر عمده العاصمه النمساويه فيينا
اقيم حفل تكريم خاص للبروفيسير النمساوي
من اصل سوري انس شقفه
هذا الرجل الذي تجاوز عمره 80 وراس الهيئه
الاسلاميه في النمسا سنوات طويله افعاله
وجهوده لا تخطئها عين عبر اجيال متلاحقه
شاهده على انجازات مسلمين واندماجهم في
النمسا ومحيطها اكثر من 800 شخصيه سياسيه
وبرلمانيه واكاديميه من وجوه المجتمع في
النمسا حضروا الحفل الذين نظمته بلديه
العاصمه بينهم الرئيس السابق للنمسا هاينز
فيشار
انا الشقفه الذي يكرم اليوم كان قبل عام
ونصف فمتهما بالارهاب من وجهه نظر الحكومه
النمساويه
ظهر الرجل ضمن برنامج الجزيره ما خفي اعظم
في تحقيقه الذي كشف بوثائق وادله حصريه
مسربه حمله ممنهجه ومنظمه قاده الحكومه
النمساويه برئاسه المستشار السابق
سيباستيان كورس لاتهام شخصيات ومؤسسات
اسلاميه بالارهاب وقد كان انس شقفه من
ابرز هذه الشخصيات
بفضل الوثائق والادله التي عرضها تحقيقها
خفي اعظم وبعد معركه قانونيه ضاريه تمت
تبرئه البروفيسور شقفه وعشرات اخرين
واسقاط تهم الارهاب بحقهم الحقيقه الجزيره
سلط الضوء على الملف بالكامل وانت تعرف
الموضوع يعني طال كثير من الاشخاص واكثر
التهم
حفظت ايضا لكن بامر محكمه واما في النسبه
لي شخصيا فلم تحلل المحكمه وانما المدعين
نفسه الذي بادر بالتهمه حفظ الملف وقال
انه لا فائده من الاستمرار في التحقيق
لانه لا توجد دلائل من بين حضور الحفل
الشاب الفلسطيني اسامه ابو الحسنى الذي تم
تكريمه سابقا لانقاذه شرطيا النمساويا
خلاله هجوم مسلح وقع في العاصمه فيينا كشف
تحقيق ما خفي اعظم ان اسامه كان احد ضحايا
الحمله وادرج اسمه ضمن قوائم الارهاب قبل
ان ينال البراءه اخيرا تغير بعض الاشياء
الايجابيه حصلت على البراءه من المحكمه
العليا ولكن للاسف بعد فتره
ارسلت كمان على
تم رفض من ناحيه الجنسيه النمساوي
وحاليا يعني المحاميه الخاصه هي يعني
شغاله بالموضوع وتعمل بالقوانين
الحكوميه هون اراد حفله تكريمي البروفيسور
انا الشقفان يعكس صوره تتجاوز الصدمه التي
تركتها عمليه الاقصر وهو الاسم الذي
اختارته الحكومه اليمينيه النمساويه
للعمليه التي داهمت السلطات فيها عشرات
المنازل والمؤسسات الاسلاميه الفاعله
عمليه تركت جدلا كبيرا وحادا في المجتمع
النمساوي وفرض التحديات جمه على مسلميها
حاضرا ومستقبلا